my daughter my youngest our loves doing
makeup do your daughter's love doing
makeup my oldest daughter is a bit of an
artist and she likes doing more fantasy
makeup so right now she's in a tick-tock
and yeah she like on this and she likes
doing graphic design and and so this is
her doing graphic design makeup on
herself but she also likes to do almost
like it looks kind of like anime ish
clownish with like she puts freckles on
her self and like orange brush it's fine
I walked in I I want and the other day
my daughter was getting ready like first
go whatever and I swear she got into
some kind of makeup I didn't know she
had and she looked like Mimi from The
Drew Carey Show like it's what she
looked like and I was like you look so
beautiful
it gets great no problem telling my
child that she's not allowed to leave
the house looking like that I have no
problems she does the whole but it's
kind of fun because it brings out the
artist during them it's really it's fine
for her to play Lauren yeah you've
described them actually the eight they
have bleeding hearts your children they
do they're the opposite of me no I mean
I started working when I was very young
and my dad I think he wanted a boy and
so while he grew you know he raised me
he's a feminist my father he always said
women deserve equal parts and in the
world and society and everything
to step up but especially in sports even
though I was a sickly kid he was like
you're not gonna throw you know he would
say not gonna throw like a girl which at
the time you know now I'm like no a
little bit weird for you to say but you
know at the time he was just saying I
want you to be you got the top level of
whoever it is you're doing sports with
so yeah III kind of have this more kind
of like rough exterior and I had a more
you know like a Latino like you don't
show your emotions like you just kind of
keep it all in oh God like I could never
be like today yeah and so it was more
like you know you don't tell people your
business and you have a problem talk to
the priest that was how I was sort of my
like toi I give way too much away yeah
well maybe we should hang out you could
use a little more of this and I can use
a little more that I could do mix but
you said your kids are actually the
opposite so my kids came out and like
everything is like oh you know I'm like
what happened and it's like my shoelace
broke and I'm like what your shoelace
like what is going on or anyway so they
dramatic they're very dramatic but it's
nice for me because then it forces me to
like open my heart and to have like
compassion and empathy for people who
are operating in the world very
differently to me yeah like me it's
full-on Karma happening at my house
though my kids are identical to me and
I'm like get over it
he was so dramatic but I love you posted
recently it was a pretty great mommy
moment which which one well it it it
might involve your son Oh
mm-hmm it might involve poo no yeah in
the bathtub I mean let's talk about it
it's like it just it was so does it
happen often
I think when he just gets real
comfortable so I know if there's like
more than 10 minutes in the bathtub it's
happening he just like gets sheared and
zero time there's zero time for this oh
my god I don't know what I'd do I think
I'd laugh so hard I would pee my pants
if my son did that I think I might go on
what I said to the girls was like not
only did you poo on me and barf on me
several times throughout your babyhood
cuz my kids get sick with motion
sickness so every car ride every train
ride every plane Bowl every single one
it's coming out and so I was like and
whilst in the bathtub with me fun to
come like you guys need to help me clean
this up gross and so I made them I love
the I roll from the elder figure that
was my face when you started your
company it was a very different world
than like it kind of what we're talking
about in our social climate right now
like for a woman to be heading a billion
dollar industry is kind of hard I mean
one of the challenges of that well um
gosh I mean eight even eight to ten
years ago raising money for a new
business was really really hard for a
woman and you know even though women
start businesses three times more than
men even now less than 2% get funding by
the venture capital to start their
companies and so there's just a huge
inequality in all of it and certainly in
corporate America and government you
know it's like a really even though
we're half the population we aren't
really seen and we're not really treated
equally all represented and we don't
feel represented because we aren't yet
we have spending power
ladies ladies we control the pocket
and so once I just once I really just
kind of tapped into if I was gonna dream
and create something I mean it was like
crazy that I thought that I could even
become successful as an actress I come
from a very you know modest background
in the suburbs of LA and I was this kid
with this dream and I figured it out I
guess I had this fearlessness and this
dream that I could create this company
that represents women that stands for
human health that has high standards and
transparency around we you know how we
operate and can be a global brand so
here like think about your product is
there any way I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this